I can't tell you right now what things
are going to be like in November I can
only tell you what things are like right
now and right now Donald Trump and Joe
Biden are seeing a shift in who is
supporting them and older voters are
abandoning Donald Trump and they are
flocking to Joe Biden in large numbers
why do we care well we care about every
vote but in particular we care because
older voters are a key voting group for
Donald Trump if you look back at the
2016 exit polls Trump won voters age 50
or older by the largest margin Trump one
vote voters in their 40s by a little bit
and Trump lost all age groups from 39
and under Republicans in general have
done better with older voters than
younger voters for a very long time so
the the important thing is Trump needs
older voters to win in November back in
2016 Trump won voters aged 45 to 64 by
4% right now
we've seen a five-point swing with Biden
leading that group 45 to 64 by about one
and a half points that's a five and a
half point reversal from 2016 normal
caveats it's early a lot can change when
we look at voters 65 plus Trump won that
group by 13 points in 2016 he is now
losing sixty five-plus by one point to
Biden that is a 14 point swing now why
is this happening
speculation it's speculation right now
someone wrote to me and said David older
folks are dying from coronavirus and
it's the Trump older folks that are more
likely to die
because they're not wearing masks are
staying home I understand the logic of
that it's been floated we don't have any
evidence for that right now
coronavirus in general is the most sort
of obvious explanation older folks are
most at risk from coronavirus and they
might react the most strongly to Donald
Trump's mishandling of it this problem
with older voters that Trump is having
could explain why Trump is not doing
well in states with older pot
Relations Florida is one such state
that's a key state Florida's population
is the fifth oldest in the country
the latest polls have Trump losing to
Biden by six in Florida more importantly
for today's story
Quinnipiac has Trump losing by ten in
Florida among voters 65 and older so I
don't want to get anybody's hopes up
we've got to count every vote this is a
snapshot right now but if Trump loses
older voters in Florida by anything
close to 10 even by 6 or 7 it's over
for Trump now if coronavirus starts to
wane if the economy recovers or appears
to recover and Trump can attach his name
to the recovery things could turn around
very quickly so you know when you start
slicing and dicing the electorate in
this way it's really difficult to glean
anything super useful from it what I do
think is interesting is the following we
believe that about 13% of people who
voted for Obama Biden in 26 2012 voted
for Trump in 2016
13% of Obama's 12 voters went for Trump
in 16 if Biden can get back just half of
those people and not lose anybody that
voted for Hillary that translates to a 7
million vote victory in the popular vote
for Biden in 2020
now you could win the popular vote by 7
million and lose the electoral college
it's theoretically possible it we've
never seen it we've never seen it so now
go back and think people who were on
board with Obama in 2012 and voted Trump
for some reason in 2016 are they likely
to stick with Trump over a guy they
already voted four years prior and Joe
and Joe Biden if he only gets half of
them back it looks very good for Biden
again nothing is guaranteed if Biden can
win back just half of those voters who
went from Obama in 12 to Trump in 16 he
has a very very good starting point for
2020 so what does this mean for us
nothing all it means is every single one
of us needs to vote remember that on
Monday Memorial Day will have a huge
David Pakman show
membership special get notified on
Monday Memorial Day by signing up for
our newsletter at david pakman.com it's
quick it's easy it's free and then
Monday you will hear about this
incredible membership discount no time
for the voice mail I'll talk to you on
the bonus show today if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink its link Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video